this perspective on the left that is so
detached from reality and you see it in
multiple Arenas right right now we're
talking about you know defense of your
own life and defense of your own you
know yourself to think that you don't
have that right to think that the state
should step in and put you in jail
because you had the audacity to try to
defend yourself and other people is it's
a terrible terrible attack on on
individual rights and I think that the
more we can do to shut it down the
better where were the social workers
yeah I want to know I mean why weren't
they why weren't they there sooner to
your point why aren't people interested
if you're supposed to be used to this uh
every day isn't that sad that we would
live in humanity where you're watching
someone suffer a mental illness because
that's what we've all agree on you're
nearly was extremely troubled mentally
ill uh and your reality is that you
think that we should just ignore it that
we should just pretend it's it's normal